ils viennent là donc et alors c'est
bizarre parce qu'il gratent pas les
champignons à côté mais bon vous avez
beau remettre la pelouse et puis voilà
chaque fois il y a creuse alors il doit
y avoir un trésor je sais pas quelque
chose pour quoi il creuse toujours au
même endroit au quartier monjoyeux
plusieurs riverins ont pu apercevoir la
nuit de curieux voisins comme ici sur
cette photo il y a quelques jours un
sanglier vraisemblablement en quête de
verre a labourer cette portion de
pelouse et quelques pas seulement des
habitations qui est une nourriture et
quête d'un nouveau territoire semble
avoir attiré des sangliers jusqu'en
pleine ville très certainement venu du
sud par laadis une dizaine de spécimens
a été observé entre le rond-point de
l'Alouette Ladis et les venue de
Bordeaux une laille a élevé ces petits
les autorités craignent une propagation
de ces animaux considérés comme des
nuisible le sanglier quel que soit le
milieu dans lequel il se trouve qu'il
soit en milieu naturel dans dans son
milieu d'origine ou qu'il soit en milieu
urbain est un animal imprévisible et
c'est un animal qui est susceptible euh
sans raison apparente d'Ille d'ailleurs
de charger pour se défendre s'il se sent
agressé et c'est pour ça que la première
des choses à faire si on aperçoit des
sangliers en milieu urbain c'est de ne
pas les approcher c'est au contraire de
s'en éloigner et de ne surtout en aucun
cas leur apporter de la nourriture
aujourd'hui le groupe semble s'être
dispersé depuis le mois de juin des
pièges pour les capturer ont été déposés
en 20 quelques-uns sont morts en
occasionnant des accidents de la route
aujourd'hui les autorités étudient la
possibilité de les tuer pour prévenir
tout incident